former vice president pence is about to
make his first public appearance since
thursday's hearing and for more on that
let's bring in chief election and
campaign correspondent robert costa he's
in chicago where pence is giving that
speech later today bob good morning to
you what do we expect from vice
president pence's remarks today and what
might they tell us about this split
clearly between the former president and
the former vice president
tony good morning good to be with you
later today just across the street at
the university club in chicago former
vice president mike pence will deliver
what is being billed as an economic
address like so many republicans he
wants to move on from january 6 but
former president trump clearly does not
want to move on still battling his
former vp and rallying his supporters to
echo his own false claims about the
election
bob we're having this national
conversation but there's a state level
conversation going on as well what are
you seeing at the state level with
regard to belief in the big lie about
the 2020 election
part of the reason pence is here in
chicago is he wants to try to run for
president in 2024 he wants to be a
leader of the gop but it's becoming
increasingly hard for someone like pence
to be in that position because across
the country the big lie remains front
and center inside the party just over
the weekend the texas gop passed a
resolution saying that president joe
biden his presidency is illegitimate and
this is being repeated in other states
in similar ways
that's the big worry going to 2024 bob
thank you very much